don't believe your senses any longer.
But uh what's happening is I think way
deeper because you use the the term
identity and for many people identity is
basically your personal details as
written in your driver's license, ID
card, passport or whatever.
And for at least two decades it's not.
You actually are have multiple
personalities out there because identity
is what is what determines that you are
you. Michael is Michael. It means that
basically your face picture is your
identity just as well. Even if I don't
know any any fact about you now you are
using your phone in order to even
identify yourself. That means that your
phone knows it's you. Okay.
Now take it further into IOT into other
things. You understand that the whole
idea the whole concept of identity is
not as we know it.
And that is why the ident the idea of
identity verification also changes and
fraud with it.
[Music]
So
identity is changing. Well, identity is
kind of saying the same because we have
identities but we're now creating our we
have evolving digital identities. The
world is becoming highly digitized. I
call it the perfect storm is ensuing
where on one hand everything is becoming
digitized. On the other hand, h you have
the emergence of more sophisticated
workflows which require the automation
of identity verification. But you have
new sophisticated tools like the
creation of deep fakes in audio and
video which are now compromising the
integrity of of the way in which we
first perceived this concept of identity
verification. In in your eyes, how is
the advent of AI generated content, deep
fakes, and these types of attacks, how
is it re-evaluating and changing the way
that we're thinking through
identity verification and digital
identities? What really is the the
change or the evolution that we're
experiencing here?
Look, in one word, don't believe your
senses any longer.
But uh what's happening is I think way
deeper because you use the the term
identity and for many people identity is
basically your personal details as
written in your driver's license, ID
card, passport or whatever
and for at least two decades it's not.
You actually are have multiple
personalities out there because identity
is what is what determines that you are
you. Michael is Michael. It means that
basically your face picture is your
identity just as well. Even if I don't
know any any fact about you now you are
using your phone in order to even
identify yourself. That means that your
phone knows it's you. Okay.
Now take it further into IOT into other
things. You understand that the whole
idea the whole concept of identity is
not as we know it and that is why the
ident the idea of identity verification
also changes and fraud with it. Now you
are specifically about
uh about def fake or generative AI.
What generative AI is is actually doing
it's undermining the one element that
still remained in identity verification
which is human saying it's you
because uh even now if I now wanted you
to you want to open an account you'll be
asked to submit a picture of your ID
whatever ID facility you want and a
picture of your face now the data on
your ID document, driver's license,
whatever it will be,
is useless
because the statistics is is is simply
saying that uh you know that on this
planet there's something like 8.4
billion people in darknet there are it's
estimated there are about 10 billion
identity credentials compromised on
sale.
So if I now want to identify you based
on your name or whatever details, it's
as if I they are written all over the
place in a billboard. It's useless to
know it's you. That's why what basically
uh generative AI or defect as we as now
it's called is doing it's aggravating
the situation because until now you know
that probably your ID do ID um
credentials are out there in your
profiles on darknet whatever you want.
So one says good but my um my look my
face my fingerprint my biometrics is
then the one certain thing that I can
use but if I can be you so easily and
you'll be amazed by the way of uh about
the things we see then even your
biometrics is not safe anymore you have
an identity problem. So, what it sounds
to me is that you're saying, "Okay, we
we've gotten to a point where we know
that the that the idea of your our
identity as documents, as as you know,
these biometric uh entities, those have
been compromised and and you know, it's
crazy to think 10 billion of these in in
the darknet. And now you're saying
effectively given the idea, given the
fact that we can now take an image of a
person or a tiny sample of their voice
and recreate their look and and voice
and and face. Now we're compromising the
other half of the spectrum which was
potentially used to help mitigate some
of the uh some of the perception and and
and I wanted to take it now to a more
business setting. So, so attackers now
have a plethora of tools to do this to
compromise both the the biometric
documentation as well as the actual
biometrics of the the person either in a
real-time setting or also in an offline
setting like taking a selfie or a video.
Where within organizations is this
impacting? What are the main flows that
you're seeing across enterprises or
organizations where this is now becoming
a top-of- mind problem or has been a
top-of- mind problem for or for business
workflows.
I don't know if it will make you feel
better but organizations normally
outside the university you know in real
life don't actually take action to be
equipped with the with the best possible
defenses
they do that because they need to comply
and they need to comply because there is
a whip or a stick if they don't and the
whole idea of fraud defense is something
that costing you money So it is not the
case in real life that if if companies
knew that we have a second line of
defense that is capable of detecting
uh professional organized crime level
fraud, they would do that necessarily,
it will cost them. And right now the
market in the world by the way basically
I I just checked it uh is in a
recessionary mood. You want to save not
to spend. So I can say that regulations
are the identity verifier's best friend
on that level. So there is awareness
obviously we are being asked about it
obviously
but what happens is that eventually if
you're looking at the evolution
uh from this point on probably identity
verification will uh coincide or meet
cyber
as you know it.
Okay? Because it will have now to verify
the device you're holding. It will have
to verify
uh everything on an ongoing basis. You
will not have to take your a picture of
your ID again. Okay? It will all be on
your mobile. So, it's kind of well, you
know, it's basically big brother, but
you will want it and it will happen. Not
because companies want to defend you but
because they are forced to do that. So
at the same token that your um internet
your ISP your internet service provider
uh has uh anti virus or cyber security
uh elements in their service. the same
way these will be implemented in
organizations that give you financial
services, government services or
whatever services. So once again it's a
situation whereby
the normal I'm seeing lots of articles
about uh 10 tips how to protect yourself
against um identity theft. That's as
ridiculous as 10
um 10 hints on how to uh prevent a cyber
attack by a whatever organized crime on
yourself. Theoretically, yes. But you do
not if if identifying you is an ongoing
thing, you expect me to be alert
uh almost um in in a kind of
life-threatening way. It doesn't work.
So basically identity verification
becomes as grave as professional
and as requiring assets that normally
people do not have in order to really be
effective at it. So the answer about the
organizations is that they will do it
once they are forced to do it. We need
regulators to do that and usually
regulators are very aware. I'm I mean
I'm meeting them on an ongoing basis
but they usually take action way later
than the threat actually arrived
and the definition of what exactly you
are required to do are usually very
general.
Now it seems to me that the context of
identity
as a cyber security threat has a pl has
a flow where it threatens the integrity
of know your customer onboarding
in call centers perhaps for account
takeovers in areas where you are
performing a really a um an active
identity verification process as we've
known to happen and we've seen I think
through co and since then this
expectation that a lot of these
processes will become automated and it
will empower users to to very quickly
interact with their services even if
they're sensitive through biometrics and
through identity. I'm also seeing
another thread where identity compromise
has become a really big issue in where
in the context of fishing and social
engineering. So looking at a more even a
bigger piece of the puzzle for
organizations where if now we can no
longer believe our senses yet you and I
are corresponding now on a video call
and I'm assuming that that you are you
then all of a sudden this idea that we
as humans and employees are performing
this continuous identity verification
even if we didn't know to call it that
but that's effectively what we've been
doing just using our eyes and ears. Now
that has also been compromised. How are
you seeing these two threats? Are they
are they fall do they fall into the same
category? Are they different threat
classifications?
What are you seeing? How how are you
seeing businesses engaging with with
these two as separately or together?
Can you rephrase? I did not understand
the question.
Absolutely. So it seems that one thread
is there's identity verification
processes where I'm asking for documents
and I'm asking for you know to take a
selfie to prove that you are you and and
those are inherent workflows that are
built into the to the ways that are to
the to the product.
Yeah. But it seems to me that today
identity compromise is also used more
generally for fishing and social
engineering on a broader range of
employees like IT help desks like those
that have access to financial accounts
where they may go on a video call with a
deep fake. How is this a threat that's
that's here? Is it coming? Are
organizations aware of it?
Well, if you follow the the news, you
will learn that already um a couple of
large scale organizations, usually
banks, have already uh transferred money
to people who uh are not the CEO.
And actually you you touched an an
interesting point because we talked
about the fact that um your your
identity facility is becoming your SSI
your sing your um um self-s sovereign
identity on your phone.
um that means that cracking that phone
or getting that credential and it's it's
encrypted is not that easy. You actually
need a uh quantum computer in order to
do that. And that's why we already see
and that's touching exactly what you
said. Fraudsters, especially
professional fraudsters, st starting to
um veer off account opening
into simply calling those help desks and
calling those uh service back offices,
impersonating you and basically instead
of opening the account getting the
transfer made. So they're actually
resulting because of that transfer into
digital
into uh impersonating you live
uh in front of those who are already
providing you the service.
And that's a good um a good step from
obviously their point of view because
once it's digital you have to work hard
if it if succeed at all in compromising
that uh that uh credential but you don't
have to. One thing that uh we learned is
that fraudsters are highly
uh effective people. We are seeing them
responding very quickly and addressing
exactly two types of targets.
first target where it's the easiest and
right now once you have a digital ID the
easiest is not your digital ID is you
calling your bank or you calling your
whatever and the second one would
obviously be where it's the most
lucrative and lucrative usually would be
the surging markets like I hope you
invested in crypto because right now
it's 97 98,000
so once It's it's peing uh you see a lot
of professionals going there because
obviously every bitcoin you compromise
is a lot of money but the idea is that
what deep fake is doing is it came in
the right time so to speak in order to
uh enable process to avoid the hard work
of trying to get into your phone and
steal your credentials or copy it or
whatever and simply call your bank and
say, "Listen, I need a transfer and it
looks like you and it talks like you."
And the tools have I think in recent
months I've seen tools I've never seen
before. Not to mention the evolution of
those tools is in fast forward
fraud as a service.
many still think I mean at the onset
I've seen uh professional forces using a
whole range of tools to perfect the
movements the voice the the injection
etc. Now I I'm I mean I cannot show it
to you in order not to give people the
wrong ideas. Um you simply um you have a
menu and you choose which organization
you want to to attack or to compromise
be it a bank be a crypto the system
already knows what their uh process is
what will be required of you active
phase liveness passive phase liveness
what would exactly happen there now now
you need to just choose which document
you want ID driving license whatever
of of which whatever country you want,
what personal details you want there and
what face is going to be there. From
that point on, you click the button and
the machine will dial in, start the
process, present on screen or inject on
screen exactly what it needs to to meet
the requirements of that website.
And it's not that that expensive.
All right. So, the the problem is in
front of us. H it it almost feels like
uh this perfect storm that I'm that I
was alluding to before. Um you're seeing
it in action and it and uh and I and I
can I can see it in the in the way that
you're speaking.
What what's next for us? So from the
context of security now and as
authentics you are you're one of the
leading providers in the world for for
this type of for this type of problem
space. What are the most important
solutions to be built or being built
that would suffice to counter this? do
and how do you see this space evolving
over time very tangibly as solutions
because it al it all it also seems like
we need to put these solutions in the
market now it this is not a 5year
problem this is a here plus 6 month
problem
yes um
I would say that um that um
even
the detection of let's say the more
advanced types of fraud the generated AI
fraud is actually in somewhere in its
childhood
okay I'm when I'm looking at all those
engines there are at least uh 8 to 10
engines that are known out there in the
market and when you look at the way they
work you understand that they are in
different levels
of what I call maturity
because the basic uh notion was okay um
we have AI the uh fake was produced
using AI so let's uh put on one side of
the ring our AI on the the other side
their AI we'll teach ours with zillions
of examples of what that fraud looks
like and we're good
now that's the basic machine learning
type of solution which turned out very
quickly to be not working because there
is a number of engines out there. Each
one of them probably behaves a little
bit different than the other and they
keep themselves being changed. I
remember that uh we used to catch uh
fraudsters who use the same imagery and
change on the on it or the same picture
of a of an ID on I don't know on the
sofa and change on it the face and the
personal details.
Once they understood we catch it, we
started seeing the same pictures but
someone put some randomizer in it so
that it's coming the picture is coming
from different angles in different
lightings and in different um zoom in
zoom out in order to basically create a
situation whereby you're looking for
repetition you won't find it but it's a
machine doing it. So what I'm saying the
initial thought that was let's learn
what deep fake is so that we can now see
another one and know it's a deep fake
doesn't work anymore. So the more
advanced systems that we've seen were
those that I think are mimicking
basically the later evolution of cyber
which is you don't have I mean you
cannot study so to speak every virus and
create an endless uh library of viruses
and what they look like and all that
jazz.
And as you know, detection has now uh
has now veered off into anomalies.
Okay, it's a much more efficient way. So
I'm already starting to see some vendors
in the market that are already thinking
that way in terms of we cannot chase an
ability to endlessly produce ever more
diversifying templates and and engines
etc. It has to be another way. So right
now what I'm saying is that we are just
I don't know if even the adolescence
if of defect detection it's the early
stages of it because it itself is
changing and by the way uh we are kind
of missing the the the cousin of deep
fake which is injection.
Okay, injection is much a bigger deal
than people think because once it's
there your device thinks it sees things
it doesn't see and it becomes a big
deal. So the battlefield u on that level
has changed into basically cyber
thinking wise
type of u the search for anomalies. And
one more thing that's missing in many
many companies is missing and that's a
big deal and it's going to be mandated
and that is explainability.
Okay? Because right now fakes can be so
good. I mean I'm I'm sometimes showing a
deep fake picture and a real picture and
people mistake them. They mix them up.
Okay. the deep fake looked looks better
and more real.
Okay. So, what I'm I'm saying is that
uh the uh the um
the detection is basically in the middle
of its evolution. It's right now it's
it's in somewhere in infancy
and will require uh multiple points of
detection and defense. in order to make
it and it won't stop there. and and it
sounds like you're speaking not I mean
there's many theorists that are looking
at this technological problem space and
but it sounds like you're talking from a
very practical nature of you're in it
you're actively
experiencing the vendors you're talking
to the customers so you're really at the
and I think that's what's what's
important also I think in the context of
this conversation you are living a
solution provider a leading solution
provider you're experiencing the threats
and the needs from the customers, you're
evaluating the market space and you
yourself have come to a to this
realization that one detection is its
infancy. Um, and that it's not useless.
You just need to rethink about the way
that you're performing it. It's probably
not the the traditional uh machine
learning approach of of what initially
was the AI versus AI type of approach,
right? generating zillions of data sets
and trying to constantly play cat and
mouse game. I do believe there's
probably some room for an antivirus
approach, but that approach
endlessly will be one step behind and
not one step ahead and will not allow
for the zero day attacks to be caught,
which is uh coincidentally the name for
this uh for this series, the human the
human zero day.
Well, it it is by the way and in these
times especially because the I don't
recall a technology that has evolved so
fast as this is happening now.
And by the way, any any technology you
can think about that has some
applications in porn will grow
exponentially and very fast. And once it
touches politics as it already did, I
mean, you've got that's the perfect
storm.
Okay. So you have now two problems if I
connect this to the last point. One, you
have to
shoot a moving target.
And B, even if you caught it,
there's nothing to see. I mean, I talked
about explanability, which is, by the
way, a regulatory
uh mandated requirement
that is not properly made, not properly
accomplished. I mean, if I show you
something and I tell you this is fake,
your eyes say it's it's real. So, how
come?
Does the machine make a mistake? Is it
right? So, there is here uh something
that uh once again I'm pushing on in our
company is to decipher I think I have
already an idea about it. uh to decipher
what is what counts as reliable
explanability because now explanability
is usually uh sending you back the same
picture and only there is like a heat
map or an areas painted in some red or
green or whatever you want saying okay
that's suspicious and once I'm saying
okay please remove that I want to look
at the same look at the same uh pixels
myself they still look normal
So how did you make how did these sides
go or not?
So we are now talking about I don't know
a third or whatever
um branch of this of this machine that
says if you cannot count on your senses
what would give you the certainty or
comfort or trust that this is a correct
detection?
Absolutely. Offer I think we've just
scratched the tip of the iceberg, but
I'm taking away from this conversation a
couple things. One, this is a here and
now problem. The perfect storm is is
upon us. The identity verification space
and digital identity space has been a
moving target for for a while. I
remember when livveness became an issue
a few years ago and and we're and we
feel like it's already history, but this
was just a couple years ago and now
we're faced with with the injection
attacks and the deep fakes and and the
moving target and now all of a sudden
it's explainability is a part of it. Um
fascinating time to be around. I'm sure
it's fascinating in your seat being a
leader in a company that's at the
forefront of this. Thank you very much
for being here. I really appreciate your
time. Thank you. Thank you for the
interesting conversation.